the school of life youtube channel wants
to meet you this summer the creative
behind the channel and at a bottle
that's me is going on a tour around the
united states to talk about YouTube the
role of ideas and a new book about
relationships and I'd love you to come
along to our events and say hi in person
we're going to be doing seven fun and
free events in the middle of June on
both us coasts New York City on jun the
14 philadelphia on june fifteenth boston
on june seventeenth LA on jun 19th san
francisco on jun 21st seattle on jun
22nd and finally portland oregon on jun
23rd if you're within hitting distance
of any of these places and feel like a
thought-provoking evening around many of
the themes you'll know from this channel
please come and say hello to find out
more details look at the link in the
text below the screen here we hope to
see you soon
you